[Musique]
Lindy,
ce n'est pas un
remède, la seule façon pour nous de
progresser
est un traitement d'avant-garde de pointe.
J'ai cette condition,
ça me fait craquer
comme si la tourette était juste un peu plus
intense. [Musique] intense,
j'ai augmenté  la tension
mais il n'y a qu'une limite à ce que le
corps humain peut supporter
[Musique]
bonjour,
c'est le détective Vickers, on dirait que
votre homme était impliqué dans une
affaire assez sommaire,
je vais découvrir que vous avez fait ça
si vous suivez cette voie, vous n'êtes
jamais  tu vas mieux
traiter avec elle
tu as passé des années à être obligé de réprimer
ta colère
mais maintenant tu as vu à quel point tu
peux être puissant quand tu acceptes ton âge
oh sérieusement tu vas me faire
traverser tout le visage en piétinant les os, en
cassant les dégâts  routine
ok très bien
tu vas faire tuer quelqu'un
j'essaie de t'aider uh-huh comment ça
se passe pour toi qu'est-ce que ça fait avec les
vieillards dégueulasses qui
sous-estiment toujours les femmes
[Musique]
es-tu vraiment si stupide
tu sais ce que je pense que je suis  exactement ce
stupide
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous